[Music]
[Music]
only et got an invite to celebrity
designer mark soon he knows Beverly
Hills Atelier for an inside look at his
custom creations Angelina Jolie Jennifer
Lopez Kate Hudson who haven't you had in
here yes mark has it made it to measure
mannequins on deck for all of his top
clients all to ensure the fashions fit
fabulously I don't really have to come
back in your fittings we can just build
it on the mannequin let's talk about
somebody who came to you recently
how one miss Beyonce this is actually a
jumpsuit you're making for the Queen
yeah I have three jumpsuits and some
personal clothes that I'm making and
she's wonderful so what are you making
here tell me about this jumpsuit but
again it's structured it's all boned
it's structured it's cut down and that's
whatever in of course he's saying so
that's what everybody likes is the fact
that they can move and dance it's not
going anywhere and what is this for what
didn't you ask this for this Trump
supporter she just was ordering some
show thanks I don't know where we'll end
up
show or whatever mark she is on the run
tour it's funny because I'm always
anxious to see like everybody else you
know where's it gonna pop up so Wow and
so when you're working with her now
knowing her so well how involved is she
and what is what do you know that
Beyonce wants that she's very definite
she's quick and she's definite so um and
that's what's kind of wonderful she you
know she's yet again she where anything
so it makes it really easy
how much does something like this
jumpsuit cost oh look at what's
foundation like this we're like these
are like like usually like 18 $20,000
yeah what's it like to dress her for a
show costume versus something she's
wearing in her everyday life
shows are really specific because of
whatever dance moves or whatever they're
doing Beyonce you never know she's all
over the stage so her stuff has to be
able to be versatile I'm right now so if
this is for me on the run tour what do
you think what hints can you give us
about what the costume in the aesthetic
might be that I know the things I don't
know tonight and I think that's why I
sent it ton of don't disclosure you know
agreements with everybody I kind of like
working blindly that way just give me
the parameters of what you need and I'll
make sure you have it let's make the
beautiful thing I love it
marks stunning creations can be yours
too though his exclusive Atelier is by
appointment only
[Music]